è arrivato il momento di dal titolo
dovete averlo capito la mia vita cambia
da oggi sono su wikipedia incredibile
ragazzi che possiamo festeggiare
festeggiamo
e siccome funziona quale effetto come
sospetta bella giusti ragazzi e ben
vedere questo video sono fa vj oggi
siamo finalmente perché era ora che io
fossi su wikipedia allora ragazzi prima
di tutto il lustro come si fa questa
guadagniamo su google news che fa vj
wikipedia week per la prima cosa che
compare è lorenzo sun i wiki ben grazie
a dio allora uno apre dice wow
finalmente fa registro in liberia
ma c'è qualcosa che non va e lorenzo
studi touring 7 aprile 1995 a leon
youtuber e scrittori italiani
tu sei famoso con elite name fa vigente
alè alè alè della serie finalmente l
youtuber de lingua italiana con tu sei
script
secondo voi per quale motivo wikipedia è
così ve lo dico io lo dico io lo so
questo articolo
chi le scrive in lombard grafia
milanista sono su wikipedia lombardo non
sapevo neanche che esistesse va bene è
quindi quindi solo sui ripidi cosa vuol
dire se su wikipedia non vuol dire che
c'è la tua pagina con tanto di foto
tutto tondo wikipedia per lombardo in
una sua turin in 2000 n
come è nato a torino il 2011 anno nel
all other va un canale con di già mi
chiama lasciare il gaming amato del game
e nel 2012 ovvero preso su skype e nel
2012 e il deserta il suo canale autonomi
famiglie tv adesso times el el sede
prova in informatica la cadrega
telecomunicazioni vabbè comunque il
discorso è che tutto scritto in lombardo
la parte più bella ovviamente questa
lista fidanza per un quante comte con la
contessa o nato set ad e non di letta fa
anche
anche rim ha capito c'è proprio anche
spiritoso il il lombardo cioè non so
niente io di lombardo probabilmente ci
sono i nonni lombardi che si stanno
tagliando le vene vedendo studio però ci
sto provando apprezzate in del 2017 e il
gossip online la parla del possibile
flirt con la cantante youtuber giulia
penn che la scelse basa il don video
musicale del gabry ponte dove un casino
questo e mickey pedia signori grazie
possiamo chiudere il video c'è chi ci
siamo siamo i puntini sulle ì andiamo un
po a capire cosa ne pensa google di
famiglia che siamo qua ho visto video
ragazzi recentemente fatto da daniel
radcliffe che è niente popò di meno che
harry potter che fa un video cercando su
google che cosa viene fuori quando
scrive il suo nome se tu scrivi da nera
light 10 voglia di relax altezza
fidanzata cosa genera volevo provare su
famiglia e se scrivo famiglia e su
google che cosa cerca di più la gente
quando cerca la parola fa vj allora se
tu cerchi pa vj esce fuori famiglia i
video fa vj youtube fi che i forni
proviamo però a fare domande più mirate
quindi utilizziamo il classico come dove
quando e perché vivevamo perché fa vj
perché fa vj perché fa vj si chiama così
allora partiamo col primo per ragazzi
rimane la domanda che mi viene fatta più
volte nonostante io l'abbia già pubblica
viaggia risposta quest'anno vanno
miliardo di volte quindi va beh
rispondiamo alla veloce di nuovo per la
milionesima volta mi chiamo famiglie ai
ragazzi perché quando ero piccolo quindi
avevo circa nove anni ho iniziato a
giocare online un videogioco chiamato
world of warcraft che sto gioco
incredibile dove puoi giocare con la
gente online ed era una cosa fichissima
ragazzi perché giocare online nei tempi
non era così scontato come oggi e mi
dicono che ai tempi trovai questo
giocatore
il suo server di voto york dove ho
provato a scrivere li chao e lui mi ha
risposto mazza che dialoghi da premi
nobel e appunto il suddetto giocatore si
chiamava papi gay si chiama valigia e
quindi io gli ho fregato beatamente il
nome me lo sono preso da libica cioè io
sul mio canale non ho avuto niente di
origini blocco piatto il nome ho copiato
più di fi copiato qualsiasi cosa
iscrivetevi al mio canale grazie perché
fa vj a diletta si sono lasciati
perché fa vj a tanti iscritti allora
famiglia gli ha tanti iscritti
non lo so non lo sono mai spiegato in
realtà perché sono ordinato allora
abbiamo finito qui perché proviamo
invece ragazzi a cercare il cosa toni j
cosa nasconda addirittura già la cia
cosa nasconde cosa nasconde fa vj
nasconde dei filetti di tonno cosa fa
nella vita cosa fa nella vita ecco anche
questo me lo chiedo sacco perché quando
dici a file oi youtuber la metà le
persone non sa cosa siano i più per
l'altra metà dice a che cosa c'è dentro
freddi a me lo stai chiede cosa ne so io
cosa c'entro che c'è un pietro c'è
pietro non so raga non so cosa ti fa
famiglia ecco cosa tipo famigliare una
domanda che mi fanno un sacco di persone
ancora allora io ragazzi non seguo tanto
il calcio
oh mio dio se italiano non seguì tanto
il calcio sei sicuro di essere italiano
se uno sicuro desiderio non seguo tanto
il calcio perché il calcio non interessa
tutti sono persone che non seguono il
calcio o meglio se guardo qualche
partita non so neanche come siano
composte le sue tipo la juventus si sono
di torino di tutti che sono quasi tutti
juve a torino
non so non so bene neanche le squadre
quindi cosa usa fa vige per evitare
allora per registrare utilizzo shadow
play oppure o la scatolina delegato e si
chiama scheda di acquisizione uso queste
due cose dipende dal tipo di video se
devo fare un gameplay uso l'ingrato se
devo fare un video su internet tipo
questo utilizzo charlot play cosa piace
farmi j
ho qua ci sono un sacco di cose che
piacciono a famiglie facciamo un elenco
mila sono i film e le serie tv il gelato
le granite le noci il mare la passera
gli horror viaggiare mi piacciono gli
anime piace fare foto e video alle cose
questo non si sarebbe mai intuito fuori
cose mi piacciono andiamo su quanto ho
finalmente quanto guadagna fa vj anzi
addirittura quanto guadagna 2018 2007
che la gente vuole sapere quando ho
guadagnato e quanto guadagnato ed io
andrei su una risposta
che avevo trovato su internet se magari
lo troviamo quassù donna glamour
attenzione quanto guadagna uno degli
youtubers italiani più famosi e niente
quanto guadagna ciccio gamer 89 fa vj mi
svegliavo la guerra io non so quanto
guadagni ciccio gamer ma di sicuro
guadagno di più io comunque diamo
ragazzi sul quando perché quando ci
mancava ancora quando fa vj ha aperto il
canale questa è un'altra domanda che mi
fanno un sacco di persone per quanto ci
sia comunque scritto c'è scritto da
quando avverto il che c'è scritto qua
c'è scritto sul mio canale però vabbè io
facevo già video prima con dei ragazzi
le scene con il nel decidere che mi
aveva aperto rotto dicembre 2012 facendo
horror sul mio canale perché sto
iniziando a portare voti la adora
iniziato a fare horror di qua ho
iniziato a fare videogiochi in dieci e
poi siamo arrivati oggi a questo
risultato incredibile come sempre dico
però effettivamente è vero c'è ancora
fatico a crederci guardando i numeri
gabbiano poi quando è nato quando era
tuffa vj sono nato nel 95 che è una data
incredibile perché e multiple sapete
quando tipo dovete aggiustare il volume
della radio che se il numero dispari fa
schifo se un ultimo di due va bene
multiplo di cinque fantastico meglio di
me ci sono solo i 2000 che c'hanno tondo
tondo anzi sono tre tondi che figo e se
non 2000 quando guadagna fa vj quando
quanto guadagna ce l'avevamo c'è anche
il quando guadagna quando mi arriva lo
stipendio tipo 1 che ha sbagliato a
scrivere la schiere quanto quando
guadagnano dj vj guadagna creata io
guadagno dipende dipende da quando ci
hanno voglia di dal mio stipendio non
c'è un giorno fisso purtroppo frigento e
essere fidanzato con giulia penna di
ritorno perché wikipedia allora sfatiamo
sta roba
io giulia non siamo mai stati fidanzati
però un limone cerca parte del video di
gabry ponte intendo però è sempre un
limone fa vj e morto se aumenta la
luminosità di questa fare è
probabilmente sì poi è tornato dove che
sono andati scusi dov'è questo è
successo sembra il film con hitler gator
è tornato valigie e uno scolapasta
per che cosa sta succedendo perché fa vj
e uno scolapasta fa vicini non è
solamente uno su perché ormai che
scolapasta è appurato non è solamente
uno scolapasta
vabbè io non ho non voglio neanche
aprire questi video però mi avete
scoperto sono uno scolapasta che
nasconde i filetti di tonno sembra un
placement trova però non so quanto mi
pagano
ragazzi questo questo è quanto questo è
quando però che vi sia piaciuto insomma
spero aveva risposto fuori domande cioè
quelle che si fanno di più le persone
quando mi cercano su google soprattutto
sono contento di wikipedia avere
wikipedia è troppo easy capri ponta
wikipedia i tronisti hanno wikipedia fa
vj a wikipedia in lombardo quindi io io
io io mi diversificati io sono di più
io sono di più sono orgoglioso di questo
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi vorrei
chiudere vide lombardo ma non somma di
lombardo quindi se vi sia piaciuto mi
piace anche come lo sono del tizia le se
non siete agonisti discrete e noi come
sempre ci riuniamo
[Musica]